hello everyone
i was really honored to get the
invitation and come here and speak to
you guys
and i had a pleasure to meet richard a
couple times before i don't know if you
remember me
but i spent my last 10 years in the
valley
actually in u.s and moved to u.s in
2004 when i graduated from my bachelor's
at chiang mai university
and at the time i was a science nerd
i decided to pursue an academic career
i came here got into a phd program at
case western
right um in cleveland ohio i spent four
years there
and figured that i don't like really
like academic work in the end
i wanted to get out but at the time i
think
most of the job opportunities out there
are more
research-centric positions in industry
or
in academia so i decided to try give
consulting a try
i was miserably rejected by mckenzie but
got an offer from a local consulting
firm
days in foster city in the bay area
where we work with top
20 global pharmaceutical companies for
their
streamlined clinical trial and clinical
strategies
so in 2008 that's when i graduated from
my phd program and decided to move to
the bay area
and that have changed my life because
the bay area is just very different from
midwest
so after a few years at a consulting
firm
i was working really hard and learned a
lot but in the end
i just feel like it's much more exciting
to sit on the other end of the table
where
i get to implement strategies because
consultants assumes that the world is
the perfect
so they always vouch for the best
strategy to do everything
but in businesses it's not really about
the best strategy it's about having
incremental growth and improvement so
that's just a little bit run down myself
and then i ended up in inner spring i
was
lucky enough to know the investors and
people who are setting
it up in 2012 for a little bit and they
trusted me
to run into spring and i joined in 2012
and
eventually became a leader i call myself
a chief fire starter
just because it's fun so we had a team
of eight
were based in santa clara and i want to
spend some time
really a little bit time talking about
ourselves but really today
i was invited to share my um observation
about u.s china cross-border startup
acceleration
and technology entrepreneurship i would
i was
initially thinking about how to
structure my talk
but eventually i had some materials
about my
understanding about china and why people
are interested
why there are despite of big blasts out
there
companies continue to fail in the states
and recently there are some companies
are doing well and why are they doing
well
and for the entrepreneurs that are out
there interested in going global when
then when should you do it and
why why should you or should shouldn't
you do it um those type of questions i
wanted to have some discussion around
um i do hope this is interactive
sessions so
i see a lot of people come with
different backgrounds so can i
just have a show of hands how many of
you really
knows about us china feel that you can
contribute a lot to the topic i'm
talking about today
okay we got a couple so we got some
experts in the audience obviously
and we also have some very modest people
good so um just interrupt me anytime
and hopefully this will be helpful for
you guys so let's get started
i don't have a pointer so i have to move
the laptop
okay that's okay um all right uh
so inno spring inno spring was founded
to be
the first u.s china technology incubator
i the investors of innospring really are
the shareholder of it
it's primarily led by tusk park which
is the largest innovation and technology
transfer management company for qinghai
university
and then they expanded to more than 15
provinces and cities
all over china now in the past decade 15
years
and the other major shareholder of inno
spring
is northern light vc founded by one of
the most successful entrepreneurs
who brought his own company public in
u.s and in 2005
decided to go back to china and started
his own venture firm
he also had a decade of experience
investing in u.s and china
and the reason why they these two
you know teamed up to found inner spring
was really
out of the frustration where there just
isn't
a professional run platform that educate
entrepreneurs not just immigrant
entrepreneur about the cross-border
development
about connecting u.s and china it's
about really
bridging u.s china the barriers
the misunderstanding of culture the
misunderstanding of knowledge
across two different markets and how do
we open up
opportunities to all entrepreneurs
regardless of their race
their their their background about their
successful business and the cross-border
space
eventually the world is the same space
um
given that china is the currently the
biggest internet market in the world
companies are going to go to china
eventually
but still with 10 years of
continuous effort most companies still
fail
in the space so we were founded to be
the first time
we stepped one step forward
where we establish a foundation in
silicon valley for the first time
providing a platform of support for
entrepreneurs
who really want to eventually go to
china for chinese companies who really
want to come out to silicon valley
and partner with the best entrepreneurs
and best people
in silicon valley so as i said
our business model initially in 2005 was
centered around
managing a co-working space is 15 000
square feet co-working space based in
santa clara
and at the same time we have our own
fund inno spree seed fund
where we go out and actively invest in
startups
but at the same time the relationship
really comes out the best
where entrepreneurs have some interest
eventually expanding to asia
or china market where we continue
breed and nurture that relationship to
educate them and
to help them where they should set up
their strategy to eventually help them
to bridge to a different marketplace um
of course we also
are blessed with 80 different local
mentors who help us set up a mentorship
program to help entrepreneurs grow
here in silicon valley
what really set us apart from a lot of
other perhaps
similar organizations with similar
missions
we initially set up to be a platform to
plug in resources
in a complicated space of cross-border
development
right so we be eventually became a place
where
companies can really establish early
relationships of chinese vcs or vcs
who have cross-border expertise given
that most vcs are moving to the earlier
stage
relationship building with tech
companies a lot of
chinese species across border vcs are
also doing the same thing
but they don't have dedicated staff and
effort to nurture the early stage
conversation relationships because they
just have a huge fun and they have
dedicated on
the growth stage investing that they're
doing so for us
we initially set up us to be a place
where we plug in resources from vcs uh
ie that being um that shapes our
business model where we raise
a hundred percent of our capital from
venture capitals
so we're not just any annual fund that
you see that typically exists in silicon
valley
we're an annual fund a seed fund backed
by institutional vc partners
so our fund one we're lucky to partner
up with kleiner perkins both u.s and
china
gsr ventures northern light vcs antique
android fund and cbc venture fund
to help really invest in technology
companies to open
up their existing resources their
penetration their brand
to entrepreneurs at very early stage and
help them to go through continuous seat
and android and sears a funding and
bring them
into growth stage opportunities that
helped them cut down their cost
of really developing expertise in
understanding
entrepreneurship itself in developing
meaningful relationships by
scaling the relationship out of working
with different type of vcs in various
different spaces
also cutting down the cost of raising
next round of capital
not just restricted from raising from
our
the vcs that invest in our fund we do
develop relationship to be
open so we work with other funds that
don't invest in
us yet so that models tend to work
really well
with two years of operation we've
successfully invested in 19 companies
i'll talk about those companies later
but right now we just closed our fund
too
and we brought in legend capitals idg
excel partners in south bank and other
notable vcs
who become part of the network that we
support entrepreneurs with
um so inno spring is not just local now
so
through the over the past two years
we've been really active
in developing relationships all over the
world with government
mostly government-run incubators were
private incubators
through partnership we also bridge
entrepreneurs from all over the world
to silicon valley to have them trained
to have them set up
to have developed to have them develop
the global entrepreneurship dream
we recently also opened up two of our
own offices in china
just to make sure that a lot of our
companies are growing
towards the mature stage because we've
been actively backing companies now
when they're mature they really need
someone to support them on the ground in
china
so we've spent effort of setting up our
own branch offices
and hire a staff of 20 in china to help
companies to grow there
this is our invested portfolios so we've
done 19 deals so far
and we had two successful exit
one of them is a mobile security company
do mobile
it's it's one with the exit mark on it
um that's the the one that we kind of we
invested
at their the seed round and after eight
months
they were sold to baidu for 36 million
dollars
and it's a local team and they had a bit
of global story that we could talk about
later
another one is do mobile that one
do mobile has a different name it's it's
one of the two companies we have in
china we mostly invest in local
companies but we do have two companies
that are currently located in china
do mobile development app in chinese
their name is choi
i don't know if any of you guys heard of
them but it is the second
fast-growing app in china market period
and then
just a little bit shy of the first a
fast-growing one which is wechat
so um out of we we have two
exits and the other uh 17 portfolio
companies
are doing really reasonably well we
don't have anybody
die yet but things are going well and
half of them raised significant a round
or b rounds
funding after we funded them
and this is just a metric to analyze
the aggregate status of our portfolio
companies
so um they total currently are worth
about 180 million dollars
and all of them have raised right about
67 million dollars
after we funded them for their first
round so
um so attending continue to actively
invest we do
two deals a month and we prefer early
stage deals where
you know technology founders have more
found their market fit
and we look at both consumer and
enterprise space
and as i mentioned we do have
80 mentors who help us with mentoring
founders and help with building up the
support system
and of course deal flow and referrals
um here is just a snapshot of our deal
flows and
the the kind of a distribution of sector
um uh different sectors deals
um all right so um
another uh effort that we do is really
strategically set up
uh our platform to really help our
companies to build meaningful
relationships
so um as you might already know a lot of
chinese companies really are going out
of china now
and they're really really active in
acquiring and
investing in technology companies last
year the dollar amount
invested directly from chinese
technology companies
in silicon valley alone already exceeded
1.3 billion dollars
and most people already know that the
chinese merchant
acquisition market was really really
weak until about three years ago it's
getting really really strong
so the market gets consolidated and the
chinese
market is so competitive technology
companies the giants are really
hungry to acquire talent to acquire
technology and they're really active
they're really coming out to the valley
so building relationship with them early
on also
works and it's one of the things that
attracts a lot of entrepreneurs when we
go out build relationship with them
because through us they get to connect
with a lot of companies
they're all big companies most of them
are public and because
of their own line of business they have
deep
expertise on it's quite competitive they
always think of other ways to branch out
to increase their competitiveness
and and of course bringing in the right
talent the right technology to help grow
together
um so it's just we were voted
uh by one of the independent media last
year uh
to be one of the 24 best local startup
incubator in the valley
and uh yep that's
basically it's a basic intro of us
so i want to move on to um some china
related knowledge in the discussion so
before i go there
is there any questions about you know
spring that
any burning question you want to ask me
how do you deal with intellectual
property issues across
continent and who retains ownership
we we don't emphasize intellectual
property ourselves
companies that are smart knows to hire a
good patent lawyers
companies are really smart and smarter
knows that intellectual property only
works when they actually have users it's
most it's more important to get users to
get stickiness
to to enter the market than so trying
all the ways to protect the technology
that they have
competition is the reality in china
so i would say um have all the
protections working with all the law
firms possible
but the market itself just is so
potential it's so big
for that reason alone companies should
consider going in there
they shouldn't stop because intellectual
property protection is hard
how do you pick the stocks in terms of
what are your
investment criteria going forward
and social responsibility uh can you
repeat sorry i'm not
hearing you very well how do you pick
the stocks what are your investment
criteria
oh our investment criteria um we
prefer to work with really smart
founders who
is an expanding market where they have
prior expertise and where they have
ambition to really grow it really really
big
in the early stage we really emphasize
on people
not so much on what they're doing even
though we like to see technologies but
we also need to see that their
technology is in a space of solving a
real problem
i guess we're kind of we're sector
agnostic we're just finding
entrepreneurs
are really really good and eventually
can build a successful business
a real problem would be a problem and
that existed for a while
were good for for reasons they're
probably technology related
or not it hasn't been fully resolved yet
and there will be a big
potential by solving that problem can
improve users lives
um their lives their um experience
or whatever what is the size of your
fund one
and fun two well one was small it was
two million dollars u.s dollars
fund two is five million dollars our
fund circle a fund cycle is really small
because we're backed by vcs
we are much shorter than their cycle
their cycle is generally
10 years our cycle is six so we go out
we raise a new fund every two years
and we spend all that money within two
years
do you have competitors in chinese
markets
um competitive there are a lot
there are gazillions of incubators and
perhaps some accelerators in china we
don't see ourselves competing with them
because we're really focusing on the
cross-border space
we are somewhat we are competing with
what 500 startups perhaps
trying to do but most of our competitors
are
here not so much we're competing with
incubators in china
why don't we go on to talk about china
we'll have more
general general giveaway at the end i
just see a good friend he probably can
answer that question really
wow all right um
okay
okay so when i was thinking about this
because
what i always say is everybody is really
talking about china
china market is just so big where it is
probably the most
important global story really in terms
of business
yesterday i went out i was doing a
search about china
and major business journals and i come
up so many
covers i just i just cannot say
um but it's how important china market
really is to
consider um
this is if you look at really the
statistic i apologize some of them
are in chinese because those are the
statistics about the china mobile market
the china mobile market right now it's
600 million
remember there's 600 millions of
internet users in china right now at the
moment
and we know that china has 1.3 billion
population
and there's a huge potential for this
number to go up
and it's really interesting that 80
percent of internet
users in china are mobile mobile users
it's it's enormous and if you compare
the mobile users about
users and androids and ios devices
combined
it's already surpassed u.s and
the potential of growth is just really
really big
and it's really also interesting i will
talk about that is one quarter of the
mobile users
are really grassroots um those grass
roots people never really have access to
internet i think
the only access to internet for them is
through their mobile phone through their
smartphone
it's very different from the consumers
here
after that alibaba ipo i think a lot of
people really pay attention to
technology companies in china but if you
look at
the top 10 internet giants in terms of
their market cap
you know four of them are chinese
companies um
these are not companies that grow out of
silicon valley i think a lot of my
friends who are really mainstream
they're american they still think that
no big internet consumer business can
grow
outside of silicon valley but that's not
true
that's absolutely not true
um a lot of successful u.s companies try
to go to china for decades
i mean there most of them failed um
those are just a few of them
um i was thinking about talking about
the reason
i guess it's probably going to be such a
long discussion
um but it's very interesting one of the
house store where i met
what's app founder once and he was
giving
a talk at stanford actually and
um it was interesting because one of um
someone from the audience asked him a
question
of why he doesn't build stickers i mean
stickers is a function that
i think wechat is really big about and
facebook
recently launched a lot of stickers on
there
and whatsapp founders goes i think it's
too
asian we never think about that we want
to keep the product simple
it's too asian we don't we never
considered it
and then after probably another half an
hour in
his speech and there's somebody else
asked him about his global strategy
so he was talking about his effort of
going to asia market
and and you know east asia of course
in india he said um we're we're
not successful in china he was really
honest about it
and someone asked why and then he
mumbled about another
10 minutes about it but what i see it
is it's it's it's really it's actually
quite common when i talk to people here
where when they think about china they
don't understand it and they don't
want to go there and they don't want to
spend an effort to understand it
and they wonder why they're not
successful
and then some people might become
cynical after that
so it's it's it's it's something it's
kind of you just need to have the
mindset right
so though they're just companies that
fail but recently there are a few that
are
doing quite well um i think evernote is
one of the company that did really
really well in terms of localizing their
business in china
um linking is trying now amazon is
trying now
and uber is trying now but we'll see
what happens with them
right so um you should talk about why i
bought this slide from my good friend
from innovationworks
i just want to start to talk about china
where it's really is
really big big market it's
really about the mass it is um i don't
know if any of you guys
how many of you guys have been to china
before
oh okay a lot of them how many of you
have seen
tourists with that mass anywhere
in china anyone
okay some of you did um you know yeah
last night i was
having a drink i was catching up with
one of my friend
who just spent three weeks in china he's
chinese oh we're good friends
and he tells me oh you know what i found
out this really good hot pop
place in in xi'an is where i'm from it's
a second tier city and china is nowhere
compared to
you know the population of beijing
shanghai big cities so he goes oh you
know what um
i went to this place at 4 00 a.m
at night and there's a long line i
waited for an hour to get in
so he told me that's that's how crazy it
is how many people are going out
most business most most of the
restaurants are open
till what five o'clock in the morning
and he goes
if you go to this restaurant first of
all you need to get there early because
at 3 am you cannot find parking second
there will be a long line
outside of hop hop place but there are
also small businesses trying to do your
manicure when you're waiting in line
anyone have seen that that's
that's how big china is it's crazy so
it's really
massive market so a lot of people a lot
of people in silicon valley
they don't realize that you really need
a lot of operational experience to
succeed in china
and a lot of local chinese businessmen
even though they don't speak english
even though they don't know a word about
technology they have accumulated so
such great operational experience that
they themselves do not really realize
that it's gonna allow them to take over
the world because nowhere is like the
china market
with a massive user out there you really
have to deal with this with every
business that's this is
this is the customer service experience
that alibaba has gone through
for a decade and the reason why they're
successful is because
they have armies of customer support
folks to go on and talk to every one of
them as small retailers understand what
they need
tailor their product to their need build
their product
up and eventually they can beat ebay
it's
it's really building out from small and
you really just need to go and
understand how china works and how they
think
um so china in terms of demographic
chinese internet users are much much
younger
the average age of chinese internet
users are
is 25. i mean it's it's much
younger than the u.s internet users and
even though they're younger and they're
mostly grassroots they're mostly lower
um blue color but they're the those are
the ones that support the giant business
the ones like tencent the one like baidu
um baidu last year made
10 billion dollars in revenue and it's
made
primarily through microtransactions and
their qq games
um but the average spending of a you of
user average transaction
is one rmb it's
really really low and they made a 10
billion dollar business
out of it and then
you you know that all of their software
products are free
it's you have to sell a free product so
they're really really good at making
money from a free product
so i heard i think that from that point
of view
monetization i'm sorry question
i was wondering what the profitability
of the 10 billion in revenue is
i think it's two billion in profits
last year don't know about any numbers
this year
they're they're doing really well and i
think it's they grew
about about 30 percent from the year
before
okay so the users in china they're very
young
they're actually very demanding they
expect
everything is free they jump around
products
and if you know if you decide to charge
them they'll leave because there's no
customer loyalty
none they're really good at it even the
clumsy
products that probably is is worst
alternative but it's free
don't jump on it because the internet
is the only affordable channel where
they get entertainment
information and they spend most of their
time on it
so they have all the time available they
want all the product free
and if you decide to do a company
there's not much of
employee loyalty either i mean i have
so many friends running companies in
china tell me that
the biggest thing as a founder the
biggest challenge that they have to deal
with
is to lose is to to
deal with losing employees to
competitors
across the street they would hire
staffing agencies they would
try to pay them just a little bit more
of their current salary
and just get them to leave the
competition
is is fierce and then the copycat
culture
not just from people trying to do the
same thing it's it's from the giant
companies
instead of trying to go out acquiring
new technologies new product
they're just staff and army engineers
and build it in three months
and try to compete with you so as a
startup it's really really hard to
survive there
so we have we have invested the company
the company that
became the second fast-growing apps in
china
their strategy was to try their best to
avoid
attention to avoid anyone knowing what
they're doing from
baidu tanzan alibaba and what they did
is to have a company
policy where no one in the company
is allowed to talk to anyone outside of
a company about what they're doing
what's their product what they're going
for after it how
they brought it where the company is
going
the founder and the entire team was
hiding in beijing
for a year and a half they reject every
media
they reject every friend trying to
figure out what they're doing
and they reject everything they they
refuse they
told us really early on if we were to
tell people what they're doing about
their business model they're gonna have
to
go after it they wouldn't be happy about
it so they that's how really they avoid
competition from big companies
before they figure out their own product
market fit
so it's really it's really competitive
out there so yesterday i
oh now you said last week
at lunch i was talking about groupon
someone was
talking about uh living social and
groupon so i would now then i just
searched how many companies that existed
that are
kind of in a groupon group by business
and i came up about
roughly 10 to 15 in us can anyone guess
when groupon like group buying business
is hot in china
how many companies are doing similar
things
doing the same thing and 99
of them died probably not 99.95 i would
say there are a few that survived
after years they were competing years
and years of iteration
a lot of big companies that was hot a
year ago
got cold this year um unfortunately one
of them was a portfolio of one of our
ops so
i know that but a couple of them
survived and they can still have a
really lucrative business
but it's it's competition is beyond
scale
our the company that we invested in got
a hundred million users
in china within a year and a half and
you know when they go out and try to
raise b round
vcs are just all over them they they're
competing with their term sheet they're
competing with their
valuation i got calls every day from vcs
asking me about
oh what's your company's doing can you
get me in the deal
um but when you ask them why are you so
you know why are you so interested in
this people calling me giving terms
without even knowing their founders but
these guys just saying
we cannot jeopardize losing a deal with
a hundred million users we go after
deals when any company hit beyond 10
million dollar
10 million users but if you ask that you
invested in the us they would tell you
any deals
that has users more than a million they
would they would probably go after it
scale is different this is very very
different
so a lot of people ask me when i go out
and give talks
people would ask me you know china is
is all about copycat what do you want to
do with that it's
probably the problem that spot stopped
me from going there or even considering
going to china
um but over the past two years
i've been in this space i really think
that
china is different now people in china
are getting more smarter and they're
actually very very innovative
i don't know how many how many of you
guys use wechat
okay some of them some of them
okay if you use wechat if you have
any chinese friends who use wechat i
would suggest you to go out and
really try it and compare with whatsapp
compare with facebook compare with
other chatting apps it's very different
it's not at all similar it's very
different and
it's it is better it's been better a
year and two years ago
it's really sticky i have a friend who
is american
his favorite app is wechat and he's on
there more active than i do
and he had like two contacts me and
someone else he's
really active he's sending stuff all on
one he's just
love it it's really really different
and wechat is free
complete free you don't need to pay one
dollar a year to get it
you can have a lot of friends i have two
thousand friends on there i cannot live
off wechat right now at the moment
it's really really good um another
company i really wanna i think it's
really innovative i wanna talk about is
yy.com
um this is example of another smart
business
that when you talk to you as friends
they wouldn't understand anybody
heard of yy.com
can anyone explain what it does what it
is
do you want to talk about it sorry i put
you on the spot i don't mean to
but what wi-fi does
is actually it's a very special
tool that communicates i mean this the
u.s doesn't have this culture but
in china a lot of people their own
entertainment
is uh online and uh you know looking for
some uh
like uh broadcasting with uh
little girls that uh they actually can
talk uh
have their small stations broadcasting
their singing
or dancing all those kind of things but
a lot of
happy users just by spending a lot of
virtual gifts
in order to ask you know little girls
dancing or
saying that but i mean it's not like uh
you know it's just some uh
uh uh how do you say that it's a well
just like the name right so why why it
means something that you can
um using imagination but it's not a it's
not a porn or anything but just
have people that uh have you know some
more entertainment before their
uh you know their busy life in the city
or the uh in some other factories
yeah right yeah it's a pretty good
explanation so y is really is just a
live
video streaming platform out to
more a lot more users a lot of users
it's kind of like just what justin tv
used to do
but as justin tv struggled why why
thrived and they went ipo and when they
go out to wall street and no one
understand what they do because there's
no equivalent
in u.s what they really do is they
enable
people to broadcast whatever they do
performance singing
anything they do to millions of people
in china
and they it's completely free you can
sit up and do
whatever you want you can have your fan
base you can chat with them interact
with them
it is a technology company because the
streaming was really really seamless
because we feel the cpo is he's a
he's a communication guy but what's
really really innovative
about it is they have figured out why
some of the users really like to get on
there
and they have figured out these people
given that they don't have a lot of
friends they cannot afford
uh other expensive entertainment they
like to go online
find friends they like to brag about
them
being somewhat you know economically
well uh positioned so they would go out
and find
a pretty girl on their scene by the way
they're singing
mostly it's horrible i've been there i
try to i cannot sit even three minutes
in
they're a horrible thing they're not
even the answer who are really really
good they're really awful ones
but these are pretty girls they're young
they're dressed nicely they have
well makeup good makeup they go there
and
they sing and they they chat with people
um you know people are willing to buy
them virtual gifts that's why that's how
i make money
and they're willing to spend tens of
thousands of rmb
just for one gift virtual gift on the
platform
and not just one they have millions of
people willing to spend thousands tens
of thousands of rmb
just as virtual gift because it's more
of a pride thing
if you have a hundred people in the chat
room and if the girl is
doing something funny for example you
want to be
bidding on giving the gift so the girl
is getting a lot of gift
and then the people rise to top she
might just wave and kiss that's it
quite simple um the company makes so
much money
they're making a lot of money so in fact
i think chinese people are so good at
selling product
to grassroots by the way if internet is
a big business but you should know
people who are
actually upper class they're never the
one that actually pays
the ones that pay money are really the
grassroots people they really
are they're not rich people at all so
they really supported the chinese
internet
industry economy and i just think that
people
that really understand that demo graphic
also has a chance in u.s right recently
there's a deal wish.com where all it
does is the move taobao online commerce
uh to ui selling to a lower
uh middle class clients it's like a
walmart's
client people who don't live in silicon
valley they can't afford to
they live in the midwest whoever but
those guys don't really have a lot of
options of shopping online
because they can only afford walmart
quality
clothings and fashion so it's a web
dedicated to sell
taobao goods to them because i can't buy
the quality of the stuff on there it's
just horrible but it's a different
demographic
it's chinese founders and entrepreneurs
really knows
how to monetize from poor people so i
actually think that there's a lot of
innovation happening
and um if you look into it i think china
has
definitely gone past the copy past the
copycat stage and culture
and has gone on and really have
something original and innovation coming
out
oh so i talk about this i really think
that
if chinese founders are the ones that
really knows the true meaning of
freemium because everything is free
nobody expects to pay for software
nobody expects to pay
content nobody expects to pay anything
online
but they can still make four of the 10
most lucrative internet business in the
world so
um that's that's how china is
um any questions so at this point
time check so i got it yeah time check
we're doing fine but i gotta ask
if so much is free how are these
companies making money
is it advertising or is the virtual
gifts is one thing but
is it mostly advertising that these
internet companies are doing or what
different companies have spent years and
figured out different
ways yeah so 10 cent what they do is
basically
micro transactions of about addressing
up their persona
differently in the virtual world that's
primarily where they make money from
there are they develop games so
transactions within games
purchases those are also contributing to
their revenue
baidu does it differently where instead
of
they figured out this business is
willing to pay for a lot a bit a lot
for a placement of their ad it's kind of
like what google does
but they also change the rankings it
wouldn't be a complete
organic search ranking but they changed
the ranking secretly so
they actually opened up a lot of
business that's how they make the
bulk of their money from taobao has been
free and they announced it free forever
long time ago in terms of listing but
they also figure out ways
one of the ways they do is promoted
links on the sidebar
but i think the biggest money that they
make right i think right now is through
financial services
right they um they can also open up a
tml type of
brand uh boutique stores where um
brand owners is willing to brand
themselves within the tml because it's
kind of like
a a brand that recognized um
a kind of a clean cut product where
there wouldn't be any content fit into
it it kind of a special store online
storefront kind of like what shopify
does
but they do it for small businesses but
you have to pay a lot of money to get in
okay
so i think different companies really
figured out a different way okay
go ahead how is wechat making money
they're not making money now
i think because wechat is within the
umbrella of consent
tencent is already making billions of
dollars the fact that they are able to
grab
i don't know how many users they have
definitely more than huge
two to five hundred million they have so
many users they're gonna figure
out a way to make a tiny amount of
people
pay for something i think recently have
you has anyone tried homebound on wechat
yet
okay some okay we have tried a different
a little different type of things and
little things so around the new holidays
wechat has launched a home bar where you
you can set
you can send a gift it's kind of a cash
gift
to your friends but they gamify it where
if i were to send
twenty dollars for example to a hundred
of my friend
they need to click a button and do a
lottery and the lottery come
out different results right i have oh by
the way i have made
2000 rmbs just to get home bouts around
the new years myself
and i was so addicted because you have
you see someone sending out
a home bao to a group you want to click
on it
and you want to click it so so if you
get lucky you get the biggest lottery
and then you
brag about it that's all it is it's not
a lot of money
but they take a little bit transaction
fee to get money in and out because
they're trying to do financial services
now
but it's a really fun game um really
addictive
there are some other things well they
channel a lot of shopping now
into wechat almost like a mobile portal
of a customer service
or even mobile stores so you can i have
no one of my friend
he doesn't have an online store his
online store is
completely 100 within wechat so you
could buy
stuff in wechat you use wechat pay
that's the payment thing that they
recently
announced and of course their service
fee
so there's the different ways they could
do it
i'm i'm very interested in the
difference between
usn and china in customers and so
i think i and you say that china isn't a
more
mobile center centrally and
and you uh show within a more
customizable
use in a social network and service so
i think gonna do within them may
might make the landscape of the markets
in a different internet
so uh customers may
differ behave differently from
the usa so uh
and that it makes sense sorry
i guess the the amount of social
interaction social network interaction
is high and especially what you're
talking about the grassroots users that
that
is their entertainment right i mean i
think that's a real revelation
that it's not the people that you think
of as having a lot of money
it's really the people who just have a
little bit and a cell phone
yeah and this is you know what they're
doing to
enjoy themselves yeah micro payments but
huge mass and you know basic service
expectation is free but people will pay
for something if they see value in it
yeah even if it's something like a
virtual gift or uh you know
home bao that is um basically a limited
lottery
yeah uh so yeah this is great let me
suggest that you finish up your
prepared remarks first and then we'll do
general q a
okay great so all right um
i just want to land on some discussion
about going global because i've
got a lot of people ask me should i
when should i consider going global
should i even think about it
um and what are the criteria so
i try to set up some something together
so in general
if we go out and talk to entrepreneurs
um
we think that they they need to think
about going global
if they fit into these three things i'm
not saying this is
complete but this is three things i
could come up with for some businesses
where you have a bulk of your customers
really existed
outside of your um your hometown or your
whatever location you are
so then it makes sense to think about
global but there's another
way around where maybe there are already
enough
users in your home base but based on
your understanding of users
in a different market user adaption of
barrier to adoption could be way
lower in the different market so some
things just
gets penetrated a lot faster for example
things are really appealing to local
economy and culture like on-demand
drivers because right now china
bans driving with alcohol all together i
mean
zero alcohol right so the only man
driver business
literally was is booming in china
because of that
um some things just like car sharing
i've seen people trying to do car
sharings in the u.s but the fact that
everybody
have a car it's hard to take off because
the alternative is not so bad
but in china the truth is traffic is
horrible
most people just can't afford a car yet
car sharing makes more sense so if there
are equally used
equal user base between us and in a
different market
but if you think that for different
reasons that different market users in
different market
might actually adopt to your technology
or product faster you might think about
a global strategy
and the third way what i observe is a
lot of
companies might not be founded in
silicon valley i've seen a lot of
companies founded in the midwest a lot
of companies found in
europe where they wander around in
europe for example
they can't get funding because the local
entrepreneurship ecosystem just isn't
that strong
and then the limited vcs that they can
have access to generally price their
product at the lower point
whereas silicon valley has so much hype
if they come here
their startup gets priced really high
and they have way more early adopters in
the valley so they decided to come to us
that's also another reason why i started
up actual branch out
but if you asked about the question one
because i have recently
one of our portfolio company asked me
about this
going global it really needs to
the timing the timing really need to be
right so typically
unless the product business really has a
unique fit of a different market
then you actually want to go there and
understand your user understand the
market
before you start building a really the
right product
if you're just a generic entrepreneur
you have an idea you don't have a
product yet you haven't figured out what
customers want
you don't have customers yet better stay
local
has that foundation and then think about
what
really is the best market to go into
so another thing would be that
understanding i think is really a big
barrier
right because if founders don't
understand a different market
going there really takes a lot of effort
and money so they might just stay
in local market and see in the future
they have
the right time and the right people
right resources to go there
um
all right i think i touched about the
last point let's just move on
um all right so just to conclude i have
a checklist
of things that you can consider if you
think about
going global and then
this may not be exhaustive list but it's
just a list i can think of just to get
you set up
i should say that as i talk about
countries are different markets are
different
i think businesses are there to work
with people to work with the ecosystem
there
instead of trying to change it so really
having the adaptive mindset
to partner up with people try to fit in
instead of trying to change it
it's a better way to think of it if you
actually want to survive
in a different market
and then for me my bias really is
if you want to be successful especially
in a
market like china so it's so different
it's really hard for
someone who has no knowledge to really
pick up their understanding of the local
market
to really need a partner preferably
local
and you need the right partner to help
you with expanding to that market
don't want to talk about government
relationships it would be
another discussion but it's something
just to look out for
usually if you have a startup with a
product within the internet industry
um it's less of a problem compared with
other type of entrepreneurship and
projects
um i think that's what i uh that's all i
have
um thank you okay that's fantastic thank
you very much
i get to ask the first question i think
a lot of the interest in people to get
into the chinese market now
is really people who came from china to
here went to school here
worked for here for a few years what are
the dangers for somebody who's been here
who is from china uh
do you find that they are generally
successful or things that surprise them
about
china now um they do
now i think i would say five ten
five years ago sea turtle entrepreneurs
are really really popular
every vc firm wants to work with the sea
turtle entrepreneurs
because these are guys that get to train
to be
professional managers they get to train
to how to build a product to how to sell
to how to work with people to how to
manage your team
um that's really important um
it's the reason why they could actually
succeed
for the record sea turtle entrepreneur
has been really successful
in china for a decade um the reason
part of reason is that there's not much
foundation competition there
and the the millennium hasn't really
rise up yet
people that they're probably of my age
and the sea church host entrepreneurs
can relate to people that are really
um pretty much the same age bucket with
them so they understand who they are
what they do because they grew up in
china
so they can vote it's easy to build a
product that appeals to them
but lately in recent years
chinese market has changed a lot the
next generation millennium
users start to come up they're much much
younger
they're in their early 20th they're a
decade apart
from a lot of sea turtles who spend most
of their year here
they think very differently and the next
that younger generation demographic
most of them have a very good economic
basis because their parents
are doing really well and they spoil
them and this generation thinks very
different
and much different than the first
generation the second generation of
immigrants who come to us and get
educated so from that point of view
a lot of sea turtles just have trouble
adapt
to that type of understanding um to
to starting out a new business okay
right let's open the floor there were
people who are being very patient go
ahead i saw your hand earlier
okay so um you spoke a little bit about
um understanding
scale as a major differentiator between
um us u.s startups and chinese artists
and you also spoke
about um how that chinese sort of
copycat culture
is now starting to be less less of an
issue which is
really great to hear um i was wondering
whether you could speak a little bit
about
the role of i'm sorry to go here but
internet censorship
and how that could impact um startups
from us who would like to enter the
chinese market
do you believe censorship in u.s
do i believe that there's censorship in
the us yes but in less explicit and
formal forms
i think you already have an answer it's
two different countries they um
they they've handled it differently
and if you it's it's like if
if i want to go out to a friend's home
i should be nice to the host because
it's their home
if i were to sell in a different country
i should apply to a law and regulation
over there
whether or not i approve it it's a
different question
sure so um what are some challenges then
for
potential you know that startups should
navigate around
or understand a little bit more
indefinitely
in order to navigate this market
i would say communication really is
important
the government there is there really is
to support businesses
and i truly believe that a lot of
startups choose to hire one person
and that person's entire job is to
communicate and coordinate
with the government that's the last
point i have on my previous slide
you really want to have the government
relationship work for you
as long as you're in an open
communication with the government
even if things go wrong you could make
it right
try not to play in the danger room just
keep the communication and relationship
working and most time you you'll be fine
go ahead that's why you asked the
question
okay because you're saying that they all
celebrate like all the grassroots people
i'm wondering like
if you can share some tips like how to
communicate with them how to
make my product you know for example is
a wechat
like product how to make those products
go viral in those scales and group
and make it all go viral right um i
could use an example of how
one of our company actually succeeded
everyone knows that apple is mostly
manufactured
by foxconn type of factories in shenzhen
in fact that the one of the most
prominent demographic of the users that
use
kwayat d-mobile our company is mingo
it's just worker factory workers and
the reason it was really it was a
coincidence they didn't know that
those workers actually liked their
product but when they found out that a
lot of local workers are signing up
they staff a team to sit outside of the
factory
gate and just sit there all day talking
to them
at lunch and dinner asking if any of
them want to sign up for their product
once they did they ask them if they like
it how
they use it in what context and what
their
feedback about the product that's how
they realize
why their users like to use it and then
they adapt and they change their product
according to that so it's really all
about getting closer to them you just
need to talk to them
very similar doing interviews understand
what they want
find out that stickiness that pinpoint
that your product hits
that really make them want to come back
to your product that's how you build a
product that they
can grow okay let's go over here go
ahead
uh you mentioned just known that that
new young
demographic are not loyal to any like
products is there any strategy around it
like building a good
brand or would you say that you just
have to make the product really sticky
or like
what kind of what kind of strategy can
you overcome
that kind of problem um
i'm not sure i can answer a question in
the best way
um but i i believe in a product-centric
strategy
i think whatever you do you need to sell
you need to get users you need to make
sure you solve
something that the users want to come
back to
i personally still think that products
is
is the most important thing in your
company
brand can really help but as you hit
the product market fit you find out what
user really really want you you go on a
projection faster
expand exponential growth brand can help
you differentiate your
message in yourself can help increase
loyalty
even though you know loyalty is really
hard
but it's it can't facilitate growth but
i personally
still have the bias of believing in
product myself
over here what in your opinion
are the main reasons why successful u.s
companies
failed in china like google what lessons
learned
um i think different companies sort of
have a different problems
google i i'm not an ex expert about um
google how how kaifu actually run google
china would really come out
but my observation as a you know on the
side was
i think china is a different market
google is smart enough to hire a group
of really talented people who understand
china to run the game
but the problem is um do you notice that
um same internet company that they may
appear to be similar
make money differently they all hit
different pain point
so as a subsidiary in china they really
need a lot of
freedom to run the business the same
business differently
i think that might create a lot of
friction because
the headquarters getting nervous because
their product is not
sold the same way the price is all over
the wack
they have to build functions that they
never be able to use in u.s
but only in china that creates a lot of
tension between the u.s and china team
eventually if the china team doesn't
have freedom to do what they do
they're going to fail it's both the
timing and the competition there's
millions of other people trying to do
the same thing
okay while you're changing your your
slide
i think i found your hand go ahead could
you talk a bit more about enterprise
software space
in china i think this is more care for
consumers obviously you invest a lot
from
cloud and enterprises how is it
different from china
um it's really hard enterprise market
has been hard for a long time
just nobody really recognize the value
of software
i would say recent years that
has started to change small businesses
has realized that for them to really
scale and compete
they really need professional internal
management i really need
um software to help cut down
their cost because you know the cost of
hiring uh
with with with talent and then
employees also rising so they have more
need
to use software to do something that
they would have done by hiring cheap
labor in the past
so i see enterprise picking up slowly
but it's definitely still behind u.s
u.s is so much a stronger market
actually the hand i saw was behind you
you had a question are you okay yes
yeah i think uh you know we learned a
lot about uh
doing the cross-border startups where
the market is in china
the question i had was do you see any
trend or any
any opportunities for the other way
around where there's a lot of
the stuff that's happening in china but
the market could be
in the us and could there be some cross
do you see any areas where
some of those could be applied for for
chinese companies to be
focusing on the u.s market right um
it's really good question um
i've in in terms of volume i actually
see
more chinese companies trying to come
out it's probably because
i'm talking to a lot of them in the
first place
um another thing is um
a lot of them don't understand silicon
valley
so they they kind of like started this
exploration type of
scene
a lot of products that don't do well
in china for the same reason people try
to come out and see if they can sell in
here
but most of them also struggle um
for the same reason because it's
different market for them to get in and
understand
chinese people are really good with
technology
i think the field that actually
succeeded was more of technology heavy
less of the sales less of a consumer
type of startups
um over time it could get better because
i see a lot of
second generation asian american or even
people who are educated here but um
they've been to u.s really long long
time ago they've spent a decade more
than that here
and those are one more of um have
have gotten over the hurdle of
understanding u.s so they might actually
be able to
have a company that can thrive but it's
still in the early stage
there are a lot more asian latimer
chinese founders applied to yc a lot of
students from berkeley from from
stanford
coming out as asian and instead of
joining big companies and they
actually choose to start a company it's
changing very rapidly because
they they're more favor of flexible
entrepreneurship environment instead of
a big corporation that has been changing
so i see that
that trend is going i would um i would
say
there will be a lot more chinese people
trying to do business in silicon valley
going forward
okay you've been very patient go ahead
hey um
i'm trying to ask you like you know you
mentioned about your car sharing service
in china before
one of my friend actually you know
started copying beijing like three or
four years ago
at that time because like most of the
you know like a uh
chinese chinese families in big cities
they have like 12 3
like cars for for each family so so they
don't need like
you know the extra like one or two cards
so they can like share with each other
but the government has a regulation like
two two years ago right like you know
there's a restriction for people who buy
cars in the big city it's like beijing
and shanghai yeah so that's why you know
they kind of like
struggling with their service right now
and also like beijing and shanghai
they're
building like 14 15 like lines you know
of subways
so a lot of people just go to the public
service right they're trying to come
come to the states to look for some
kind of opportunities because let's say
you know most of the states
you know a lot of people have cars you
know they they go to work by cars
uh what's their process to come to you
guys to help them out
and do you have any kind of um
advice for them to come to the states um
are they
this company founded by chinese founders
okay
i think um i would say if anything
we are better at knowing the space
before they did i mean we had two year
history here
we can help them plug in with people
that they need to talk to
for them to get started for us we are an
investor we're definitely actively in
investing
we're mostly interested in investing
business they're here first
but we have seen a lot of reverse
entrepreneurship happening
we haven't done any deal at this point
yet but we'll be
you know we're interested in looking at
it why do you think evernote's done so
well in china because their local team
is really really strong they're really
young okay
and they understand that they have to
start from the ground up they understand
the
product has to be free so they hit all
the checkpoints
and um and plus they have the right
partner that's really important
um the lead investor that brought them
to china is cbcvc they're also one of
our lp's
they partner up with sequoia and they
have um
government relationship and they have
really decades of experience in
telecommunication in china they've set
up
a really good ground up partnership for
them so
okay that helped go ahead so would
chinese investors be interested
in funding american startups for an
american market
oh actually we've been doing that for
two years yeah
okay sure definitely there are a lot of
other investors too
go ahead um what foreigners have been
most successful
in business in china and the context i
mean is for instance or singaporeans
better than germans
oh god i haven't seen a lot of german
entrepreneurs in china though i was just
i mean you could say oh companies found
it
okay companies um
i don't think i have the right
information to answer that i
let me suggest that i think to wrap this
session up
i'm really i want to get back to the
role of the accelerator a little bit
do you think that it's how important is
it
for a company that's starting up here
that's looking at china
to go to an accelerator um correction
we're actually an incubator we don't run
accelerators you don't call yourself an
accelerator okay no because we don't
believe that the
glowing global or even entrepreneurship
should be easily timed
so you're a combination incubator and
seed fund
yeah right where you are providing the
benefits of
seed fund investors the connections and
so forth right
yeah okay okay with that and you know
so how important is the co-working space
co-working space
is helpful um but it provide a physical
space
for us to build a real face-to-face
relationship with entrepreneurs
the benefit of that is that we see
people working in their day in and day
out
because a lot of our companies get
funding from a lot of vcs
beyond us and our investors we are the
one that knows who's working really hard
we know some companies are doing wow
we know com some company just can't make
it but it was an obvious bum investor
point of view
we know our companies it's
one way the best way to understand
startups and founders to see how they
work
i think that's a great answer and i tell
you what on that note
let's call it into the formal part of
the session today we've got the
refreshments
outside and i know there's a lot of
people who want to talk to you about
specific things as well as in general so
thanks everybody for coming thanks again
for a great present
thank you
you